[Music]
I'm just trying to get back to my old
self you know getting back into my
fashion line designing so we saw Curran
and Demario meet tonight was that what
you expected it to be no okay so I
didn't know they were gonna come out and
sit together in the couch I was really
confused but I think it's great that
they you can tell like they really don't
care like nothing happened you can tell
like they really have no harm and gets
each other I'm happy that they got to
come out together but I didn't think
what's gonna happen what's good
beautiful what is going on how does the
cast feel about what she had to say
tonight I think people are confused
because you know I do understand where
his parents coming from but I think a
lot of people were confused on why she's
not taking accountability on what really
happened I think she was maybe blaming
it on other things or people in her ear
and I think people were like rolling
their eyes because I probably like why
aren't you being 100% honest and say I
was not a victim I shouldn't have said
that not blaming the media's I think
people are just like what are you
talking about you know ultimately do you
feel anything could have been handled
differently in terms of the scandal
anything that should have been done
differently I mean I mommy I'm over it
I'm over talking about it hon it's Lisa
I don't I think that they did it's great
I'm done I'm like please I'm over
talking about it but um I mean Isaac a
great job
[Music]
you